como les comentaba nos vamos hasta
Ecuador para hablar del caso de María
Belén Bernal quien fue encontrada sin
vida en un cerro cercano de la escuela
superior de policía en el norte de quito
el presidente Guillermo lassoas aseguró
que se trabajará en la erradicación de
la violencia de género y hoy procedió al
cierre simbólico de la escuela entre
otros asuntos la Sor ratificó además la
búsqueda de Germán Cáceres principal
sospechoso Gustavo ya hemos adelantado
alguno de los anuncios del presidente de
la república explícanos ahora bien De
qué se tratan estos nuevos anuncios
Hola qué tal Rodrigo bueno en las
declaraciones fueron realizadas el día
de hoy por parte del presidente de la
república y específicamente lo hizo en
medio de un recorrido por la escuela
superior de la policía en principio se
posicionó el día de hoy al nuevo
ministro de interior y Justicia teniente
coronel Juan Zapata Juan Zapata se era
se mantenía en un servicio pasivo era un
oficial se metería en servicio pasivo de
la policía debería ejecutando acciones
como director Durante los últimos 16
meses de el principal cuerpo de atención
de emergencias el eq911 que es un
principal centro de atención de este
país se posicionó el día de hoy y luego
de ello partieron a la escuela superior
de la policía donde el presidente de la
república Guillermo lazo dio algunos
anuncios en principio él da ocho días de
plazo para que la policía
de con información y la captura de
Germán en Cáceres principal sospechoso
por el femicidio de María Belén otro los
anuncios que dio también Es sobre el
proceso de asesoría que ahora recibe por
parte de oro mujeres para poder cambiar
así la estructura de funcionamiento
formativo de la Policía Nacional y por
otro lado se ha conocido también que el
esposo de María Belén Bernal ha entrado
a la lista de los más buscados que se
sabe de esta noticia
efectivamente
el
esposo quien era el esposo de María
herrería Bernal ha entrado una de la
lista de los 10 más buscados del Ecuador
y el estado ofrece 20 mil dólares por
conseguir información que lleve así a su
captura la madre de María Belén Bernal
también ha reaccionado con indignación y
sobre todo ha rechazado este cierre es
simbólico por parte del ejecutivo de
nacional y pide acciones más
contundentes por parte del ejecutivo
nacional no solo incluirlo en esta lista
de los más buscados sucede en un momento
de mayor
crisis institucional que vive la Policía
Nacional y presidente de la república ha
pedido no rechazar Este cuerpo por el
accionar de uno de los agentes de la
policía de Igualmente para el día de
mañana la asamblea nacional llevará el
caso y el convocará a las principales
autoridades del ejecutivo nacional en
materia de seguridad y de